now from the American Enterprise
Institute in Washington DC author
Richard Epstein discusses his
forthcoming book skepticism and freedom
a defense of classical liberalism in it
the author argues that America's current
legal system is based on property rights
freedom of contract and limited
government this event runs an hour five
minutes Richard Epstein is one of the
great legal scholars of the age and one
of the great expositors of the
principles and institutions of
individual liberty in addition to a
copious literature in the law journals
and magazines and journals of general
circulation and a long tour going back
to the early 1980s as editor of two of
the great academic journals of the time
first the journal of legal studies and
then the journal of law and economics
both at his home the University of
Chicago Law School he is the author of a
string of highly important books on
healthcare affirmative action other
issues including most notably his recent
principles for a free society
reconciling individual liberty with the
common good and his well-known book
simple rules for a complex world
when I heard that Professor Epstein was
writing a book with the title skepticism
and freedom and being highly impressed
with the ambition and scope of what I
assumed the book would be I asked him
how long he had been working on this
book and he replied thirty years I think
that you can guess from the title of
this book which will be published by the
University of Chicago Press this coming
fall that it is in many ways a
fulfillment and an extension of much
that has come
before in this man's distinguished
intellectual career his lecture this
evening is by that title it will be a
sneak preview of his upcoming book and I
ask you all to join me in giving Richard
Epstein a warm welcome it is very nice
to see so many nice friends here and
many of whom go back for the 30 years
about which I've been thinking about
this and other kinds of books if this
were a crowd which wasn't so friendly I
would actually take the book out and try
to read it to you in the 35 or 40
minutes that were available to me but I
somehow or the thought that I should
take an alternative course of action
which is to try to jump from peak to
peak running the serious risk in an
exposition of this thought that I might
fall into some rather deep valleys which
I will leave unexplored in a talk of
this particular sort my view is I'm
supposed to go about 3540 minutes I
don't know the drill and then take the
questions and of course in the questions
I will manage to remedy all of this
serious defects and omissions that I've
made in the talk now and I was trying to
figure out how it is I was to try to
position this talk I said I'm now at AEI
and so what I have to do is to assume an
air of reasoned moderation in which I
manage to imitate the good and strong
intellectual and corporate culture which
is dominated this place and so what I'm
going to do is to try to describe all
the kinds of ways in which this book in
fact makes me Aristotle's main man of
the 21st century when the first of the
kinds of is how we say moderations that
I wish to talk about in this book is to
indicate to some degree the source of
substance of positions that I'm trying
to avoid and then to try to tell you
something about the methodological traps
that I am trying to devoid and of course
the appropriate strategy with respect to
both of those things is to show that
there's somebody to your left and
somebody to your right so that you in
fact have the virtues of the golden mean
and when you're trying to figure out
what the substantive positions are that
you are having to deal with under these
things one of them is in fact the
position to which I have a great deal of
affection it's what you might want to
call a stripped-down version of a
libertarian theory very powerful visions
of the minimum state in which the
essential proposition about government
is that its sole force is to avoid harms
to other individuals where harms to
other individuals are going to be
described in the narrow terms of the
prevention of force and fraud and
there's no question that there's a great
deal to be said for the affirmative case
there that you have a government that
does at least those sorts of things but
it seems to me on end that it will not
be able to account for many of the
common features of our ordinary
organizations and that we therefore have
to bolster the theory so for example it
is generally accepted that we have a
system of taxation at least some system
of taxation that's going to be
appropriate it's also clear that the
government seems to have some role in
respect to the sort of the supply of
various kinds of social infrastructure
and neither those two functions fit very
easily within this particular framework
so the question now is how do we make
government a little bit bigger than our
sort of small-time libertarians would
like it to be and it's painful to me to
recognize that we have to go that far
and one of the reasons why it's so
painful is that you might end up going a
great deal further because one of the
tendencies on the other side which I'm
equally anxious to avoid is the position
which says since you cannot give
yourself a narrow and limited definition
of what government does essentially what
you have to do is in Constitution and
political terms is to recognize that the
state that you have can do more or less
anything that it pleases so long as it
gives at least some nod to advancing the
common welfare of the good of the
population at large but that any kind of
intervention regardless of its
particular sexual program is if passed
with that kind of benevolent motivation
going to be sufficient under the day and
this of course travels into many
versions at one time it used to be the
sort of the socialist ideal that we
could figure out how to have ideal
distribution an ideal production just by
wringing the various kinds of price
indicators through central planning I'm
happy to say that a guy named Hayek got
to that issue a little bit before me and
I was able to explain I think in fairly
powerful
form why it is that that form of
centralized planning doesn't succeed in
the terms that it advances the argument
namely that it isn't able to produce the
kinds of productive outcomes that will
have mr. Khrushchev did not bury us it
turned out that the Soviet Union
disintegrated under its own way by the
late 1980s in the early 1990s it turns
out however advocates for larger
government are a very Hardy breed and in
many cases they will now take more
modest positions and the one in which I
think there's been a great deal set in
this country is of course with a sort of
comprehensive welfare state the kind of
thing that we have today in the United
States which works with a greater
success than socialism but essentially
takes the proposition that in dealing
with general matters of economic
regulation there is no powerful side
constraint of constitutional law a legal
principle which prevents the legislature
from doing exactly what it pleases and
exactly when it pleases to do this so
that a Rex Harrison's versions of what
the my fair lady ought to be about seems
to be much of the modern political
theory now in dealing with this I'm
actually a moderate because I do think
in effect that one can escape the
dangers of being the hardline
libertarian without going into a
position which comprehensive government
action is the order of the day and so
the subtitle of this book which I added
when I realized that no one would figure
out what the title man was in effect
they rather simple observation that it
was a defense of the classical liberal
position in which their relatively
limited kinds of government functions
that are legitimate and large numbers of
other things that fall outside this way
a proper government action when if one
wants to get absentia sense of where it
is that one goes without figuring out
exactly how one gets there I would say
that the functions are the ones that I
mentioned in the libertarian a I think
it also has to deal with infrastructure
and Taxation I think it has to deal with
the provision of public goods and I
think it probably has to deal though on
delicate tiptoe with the regulation and
prohibition of various kinds of
monopolies are recognized as the real
dangers that can take place when an
administrative state starts to deal with
that rather slippery subject so you are
now trying to look at a middle kind of a
position and the question is how is it
that you articulated and
and well that's the first part of this
thing now the second kind of question is
how is it that we think about legal
rules generally and I'm gonna try to be
a little bit more of a lawyer and a
little bit less of a political science
this for at least a minute and here
again there are kind of three ways in
which you could think about the law I'm
gonna mention the two that I'm deeply
suspicious of and try to indicate the
third which i think is much more
moderate and sensible than either the
extremes one of the things that's true
when you're young in this world is that
you believe that the class of deductive
truths about social matters is rather
larger than it really turns out to be
and so the great temptation of the
strong libertarian thought which I was
very very fun and still have a lot of
fun this for was that somehow or other
you could Aksum 't i's it and sort of
reduce everything to a set of principles
which you can treat is either necessary
or deductive truths of one sort or
another in fact when you go back into
the legal literature you will typically
find claims about the way in which
social propositions are organized which
appeal to either the rules of logic on
the one hand or sort of universal
physical principles such as Newtonian
gravitational rules on the other hand
and in fact you could go back and read
Locke and Blackstone in which the use of
the word law is somehow rather
deliberately equivocated so as to cover
natural laws on the one hand ie the laws
of notion and natural laws on the other
hand that is rules of social behavior
and it seems to me that this is a very
serious kind of mistake
if you look around to various kinds of
societies you see enough variety in the
nature of the laws that if all of them
are deductively required there's going
to be some kind of apparent
inconsistency in the sorts of laws that
we are going to have in addition it
seems quite clear that there's certain
degrees of evolution that take place
with respect to various kinds of legal
doctrine over time and one would be
deeply suspicious of how that could
happen if immutability with the
touchstone of the laws and in addition
to that it turns out that whatever
consensus we might have had about how
legal principles ought to be organized
is sufficiently shattered in modern
times that an appeal to self-evident
truth will fall on deaf ears by people
who believe that the self-evident truths
unmanifest
otherwise so I think that's one thing
you have to be aware of this is not a
case in which they're going to be any
cheap victories are coming out of a
proposition that we can do by deduction
or introspection of appeals through
intuition and self evidence the question
of how it is that our basic rules of a
legal system are organized now that's
one way and then the other extreme which
I also want to avoid is something which
is more characteristic of the 20th
century perhaps in the 18th century but
has had an enormous influence on modern
efforts to undermine classical
liberalism and that's the idea that for
one reason or another virtually every
proposition that you wish to assert
about the nature of a proper legal order
is necessarily infected with some kind
of a fatal contradiction one of the
things that I did in preparing for this
book was to read what I thought was the
best study on critical legal studies a
legal movement which has this in mind by
Marc Hellman in 1987 and it's very clear
that there are more contradictions
within the framework of capitalism on
two pages of that book than there are in
any logicians manual at every single
point when you start to deal with the
kinds of problems that are faced it
turns out that you discover that
contradiction is what dooms you so that
the critical legal types in many ways
turn out to be the mirror image of the
natural law types they assume that if
you articulate various kinds of
propositions you can show not their
necessity but rather their impossibility
and again it seems to me that they are
wrong for exactly the same kind of
reason just as they're no cheap
victories that are to be won by folks
who believe in classical principles of
individual liberty and so forth so it is
that there are no cheap victories that
are to be won by their opponents so then
the question is what on earth do we
start to do when we try to figure out if
we can find a middle ground and it's
here where one starts to think about
skepticism and its relationship to
freedom and its relationship to human
nature essentially as I've gotten older
maybe a little bit wiser and that's why
the 30 years really starts to matter I
have discovered to my infinite regret
that most of the serious questions that
you have to be able to resolve about the
articulation of the basic principles of
any political order have an irreducible
empirical
and that is associated with them what
you must be able to do is to figure out
how it is that you can get a degree of
generality in your understanding of
human nature so that you can do two
things simultaneously one to be able to
articulate into defense and a general
set of principles as to how it is that
you think the world ought to be
organized and secondly have a set of
principles which is sufficiently
respectful of why it is that your
principles of social organization do not
to the last jot and tittle determine
what everybody ought to have when they
want to have it and how they ought to
have it that is you have to have enough
knowledge to allow you to establish a
framework and you have to be able to be
cautious enough so that that knowledge
doesn't allow you to dictate what the
world is going on there are in effect
two forms of skepticism there is a form
of skepticism which says that we know
nothing about legal rules in that car
cannot articulate anything and that's
the dangerous form of skepticism but the
sensible form of skepticism says we know
enough about the basic patterns of human
behavior that on average we could figure
out a set of rules that is going to do
better by us than some of the
alternatives that we might choose to
develop to put it in some of the rather
fancy philosophical jargon that comes
out in modern times the intellectual
conversion that I've undergone in 30
years has been to recognize a slight
expansion in the scope of the state over
my formal libertarian self and a rather
radical and to some people regrettable
I'm looking at Roger pallone conversion
of my own intellectual beliefs so that I
tend to be somebody who's a more of a
moral consequentialist rather than a
deontologist what am I trying to do with
this kind of position it's essentially
to see if I could give firma foundations
for a lot of the strong intuitions not
of the modern socialist but of the
natural lawyer so that when one starts
to deal with the issue you can get
beyond discussions of self evidence and
try to give something about real and
material effects on human beings in
ordinary social context as a function of
legal rules this makes me an ancient in
another way I mean not in terms of my
own age but in terms of the way in which
I I think about legal problems one of
the things that has impressed me about
all of the great classical writers on
government and
individual liberty is that almost
without exception they do not start with
the question of political organization
or the question of individual rights
rather they are much deeper in their
instincts and they start with the
questions of human psychology how it is
that we think the basic tendencies of
human behavior will work themselves out
over time and what we can do in order to
understand these so that the nature
society depends to some extent on this
summit over general and grant diligence
Brent deal Gila with Randall L looked
eloquent phrase whatever the word is
about do we know something about the
nature of man and at the time that this
was said in our earlier day sometimes we
didn't know all that much about the
nature of man and that what I'm trying
to do in this study is to figure out a
way in which we could take some of the
basic instincts which are associated
with evolutionary psychology or social
biology or general evolutionary theory
and see the extent to which they give us
enough information to have purchased on
the organization of various social
institutions and this means that we want
to start with some very generalized
styles of fact to see if we could then
figure out what the main lines of our
social institutions ought to be what are
the key features of the system that we
want to talk about and it seems to me we
could start with about three one of
these has to do with individual
self-interest the second has to do with
scarcity and the third is a refinement
on the first which starts to talk about
why individual self-interest is in fact
not quite individual but rather has a
rather more complicated cooperative
nature associated with it under the name
of inclusive fitness so the biological
stuff that I studied in the 70s and 80s
comes back to haunt the legal work that
I'm doing in the beginning of the 21st
century now why does one want to start
with scarce well I think in effect that
if there's one truth that which we can
regard as being self-evident that's
going to be it if we look around the
world it turns out that there's a finite
space finite amount of land finite
amount of water and it also turns out
that the level of desires that we have
with respect to these resources are
always greater than the resources that
are available to satisfy them no matter
what the state of humankind at that
point even before you get to the
question of how legal rules in
Veen in the operation of a political
system the question you have to then ask
is what kind of personality types are
going to be able to survive in an
unstructured environment where in fact
scarcity is the dominant constraint when
the answer is there's going to be one
kind of characteristic which is going to
dominate over all others and that turns
out to be self-interest subject to the
qualification of family and inclusive
fitness that I mentioned so let's just
kind of want those two things together
for a moment let us just assuming a
hypothetical experiment that you have
two kinds of folks some of whom have
been dead benevolent and are different
to their own welfare relative to that of
their fellow man and others who turn out
to be egotistical if you run this sort
of necessary experiment what's gonna
happen is one guy is quite happy to have
a 50/50 split and the other guy is going
to end up with 7525 over time the
self-interested individuals are going to
manage to co-op more and more of the
resource base what has happened to more
and more the resource base which is
otherwise made available to them I guess
there's somebody who truly disagrees
with everything that I'm about to say
that the resource base is going to be
necessarily truncated in those direction
selection pressures are therefore going
to have an enormous bias in favor of the
selfish with respect to those who are
altruistic by virtue of the repeated and
inexorable application of the same kind
of the same kind of um shall we say
method of behavior the question is
what's the break on individual
self-interest and the answer turns out
to be generic inheritance it basically
if you're going to try in this thing if
you're not in it for the long run and
you simply want to gorge yourself on
sweets and fancies you can die out at
one generation at which point those
people are altruistic with respect to
their own children will fair bar better
than those who are selfish in that
regard so the dominant feature that one
has to deal with with respect to this
kind of situation is a theory of
inclusive fitness in which the
definition of self-interest that we as
individuals use is a definition which
takes into account not only ourselves
but those people who are related to us
genetically just this simple
modification of the basic rule means
that the strategies that individuals who
are of course the social actors take are
far more complicated than they would be
in any kind
the system in which we follow just a
naive Hobbesian view that individual
self-interest means the autonomous fella
it also means that many of the classical
critics of les de faire have a point
which could be in fact incorporated into
the system which is the idea that you're
going to assume atomistic individuals
who care nothing about any sort of
connections is in fact not an outgrowth
of the theory that we're talking about
but is a direct contradiction to it the
level of cooperation that is necessarily
required in order to implement the
genetic program therefore can be a base
by which you could form larger and more
complicated social behaviors than might
have otherwise had been once you
understand this kind of a theory it
helps explain why it is that there's a
way to get out of the Hobbesian dilemma
without getting yourself into the
terrible pitfalls of the absolute state
so the assumption that we're talking
about here is enormous ly important the
next point that we have to make which
follows from these two is how does the
resource constraint and the
self-interest work when it comes to
dealing to things in the external world
and here the basic biological
proposition that I would want to refer
to as a very simple one it has to do
with the fact that there are variations
off of median in every population and
that these variations are necessary for
survival if every individual were
exactly like every other individual we
would lose two enormous benefits one is
that we've no longer be possible to have
cooperation between individuals with
slightly different skills because in
fact the gains that you would get from
trade would be reduced very
substantially by the identity of the
kinds of individuals in question and
secondly your ability to be attacked by
external perils for example dizzied
would be markedly increased because once
you're the Dutch elm disease tree you
wipe out the entire industry because in
fact there's no variation which allows
you to have certain degrees of
resistance but variation over what and
it's here I think that we can see some
of the dangers of moral relativism one
of the words that we use in everyday
language to describe the products that
we can disperse in a marketplace is the
term good and the term good is not just
simply fortuitously related to the idea
of individual good quite the opposite
the reason we tend to call these things
good is because we know
on average that they are going to
improve the fitness of those individuals
that consume them unlike waists and beds
which are going to have exactly the
opposite effect with the people involved
in any particular case and the reason we
know that there is basically a
distribution which is on the positive
side and on the negative side is we know
in effect that the sort of caloric
minimums that is necessary for everybody
to live creates a kind of imperatives
that are jointly shared so that what
happens is we now understand essentially
the basic explanations as to why it is
that people need territory which then
becomes property why people need bodily
integrity which then becomes the
principle of autonomy why people need to
cooperate in order to expand their
possibilities which becomes the
principle of contract the question then
is how do we start to explain this in
other kinds of terms well here we have
to have an objective theory what is it
that we're trying to achieve when we
start to impose laws and simply to talk
about this as though the sole object
were individual liberty is an end in
itself this is the very important
question of whether or not the actions
that one individual creates will have
systemic negative consequences with
respect to other individuals and if
those negative consequences do occur
what if anything should be done in order
to counteract them and so now what you
do is you start to put all this stuff
together and it starts to give you some
indication of the way in which the basic
system is going to start the fit and the
first thing that you start to note is
that the autonomy principles are
extremely strong in any legal system
because the moment you allow somebody to
break the bone or to penetrate the skin
of another person
then death is going to be the
consequence on one side through
infection or exhaustion of bloodletting
or whatever it is and the gains on the
other side are going to be relatively
small and the great insight of all the
social contract theorists is to the
extent that you engage in the mutual
renunciation of force we are confident
given the commonality of our human
origins that all of us will gain more
from its relaxation weathers from the
imposition of this prohibition then they
will suffer from being bound by this is
not a necessary truth it is something
which you could deny but it is not
something I dare say that you could deny
with a straight face
and the great reason why it is that
social contract theory has always tied
in with general utilitarians theory is
one of them sort of talks about a method
of hypothetical exchange and the other
starts talking about the gains that real
exchanges and by definition
hypotheticals changes or to achieve so
much of the utilitarian tradition and
the social contract tradition are
finding rather different ways to express
what is called the same fundamental
truth this then gets pushed on because
when you're dealing with these duties of
non-intervention the only way it turns
out that they will be effective is to be
universal it does me no good to say that
old pallone cants knife me because he
disagrees with my political theory if it
turns out that vilnius cannon could take
up the cudgels and do the job for him
what is essentially critical in all of
these cases is that unless you have
absolutely nana midi with respect to the
principle your worst enemy will be the
one person who will do you in and the
gains that you get from everybody else
will no longer suffice so that what
happens is since we know that actual
contracting is not possible this becomes
the absolute universal social imperative
non intervention enforced in some method
which we'll talk about in a moment has
to be something that we want whatever
the variations that we have amongst
ourselves as individuals if we don't
follow with this particular kind of
requirement we're not going to succeed
with anything at all now the next
question is how do we take into account
the variations and here there's a very
powerful legal parallel generalized
rules in RAM that is good against the
rest of the world tend to be negative in
form and universal and application
easily observable they are rules in
effect that worse no matter how large or
small the population is so whether
you're talking about Rome of 1 million
or the United States of 300 million the
same negative rules can apply perfectly
well to the large number situations you
face but as I've also indicated to you
there's a power level of individual
variation and the question is how is it
that we try to exploit that and we have
basically a one-word answer we try to
exploit that through exchange and the
basic theory here is as follows as a
structural matter if you're having
voluntary exchanges you could be
confident at the eleventh commandment
the one they forgot
right on Sinai but should have written
there will apply and it's one which has
been beaten into my head for 20 odd
years and I'm gonna say it again is that
voluntary exchanges result in mutual
gains for the parties so that what
happens is the presumption is and I use
the word presumption here very advisedly
that the mutual gains from trade are the
things that may contract off now the
important thing for these purposes to
note about this general proposition is
that the reason that these kinds of
contracts make things go depends only on
our general knowledge of the bare
features of human behavior it does not
depend upon our knowledge of whether or
not you like carrots or whether or not I
happen to be allergic to broccoli and so
what the system says is in effect is
this we know about these variations and
the reason why we have private ordering
with respect to voluntary contracts is
that the private knowledge that people
have about their own preference
structure is essentially superior to any
collective knowledge that people have
about constructive preference structures
writ large and so that the whole point
of the system of the privatization of
contract is to make sure that the gains
from trade which are otherwise available
or achieved and that can only be done by
exploiting the private information and
the genius of the legal system is it
doesn't have to know what the private
information is in order to be able to
validate the information all it has to
know is that the preference maps of
different individuals at different times
are not identical to one another so that
gain from exchange cannon produce
improvements in welfare and that those
improvements of welfare have the
following additional characteristics one
good idea apply two million times is an
idea which generates a million games is
Robert Nozick my good friend and I think
a lot of good friend friends were a lot
of people here emphasized when they
talked about the redistribution and his
rules of transfer is that whatever you
receive in one set of transfers you can
use in bargain in the next set so that
the recursive nature of the exchange
principle allows you to get incredibly
complicated forms by the successive
application of a single given idea and
that in turn informs what becomes the
major exercise in the law of contracts
which is how it is that you reduce the
transactions cost associated with these
transactions
so as to maximize the velocity of
exchange and in some cases it may
require formalities and in other cases
it may require their elimination but the
basic technique is they're given the
objective which comes out of what it is
that we have now the libertarian
prohibition on force and fraud of course
is done for exactly the same reason
going in Reverse given our confidence
that if you can do something voluntarily
it's a mutual gain we start to have very
deep and profound restrictions at any
time you use force or aggression against
another individual it's a victory to you
it's a loss to somebody else we know
it's not a Pareto improvement and most
of the time we don't believe that it's
any kind of improvement at all we tend
to think that the losses are enormous
and the gains are very very small and
that's why we have the prohibition on
the use of force and the use of
deception deception is a little bit more
complicated than force but essentially
the basic argument is that when people
lie what they do is misrepresent the
relative value of two things in exchange
so that the victim in question is going
to turn out to be a net loser from the
exchange in question now what I did in
effect as I said that these things are
presumptions and it's extremely
important to explain why it is that the
presumptive language has to be used in
here and it's another form of skepticism
if you are really confident about
everything that you say you don't
believe in presumptions you tend to
believe in absolutes and whenever you
believe in absolutes what happens is you
come up with cases that seem to fall
within the principle but by God when you
look at them they seem to require a cry
out for treatment in the opposite
direction and one of the great
weaknesses of standard libertarian
theory is that it tends to push too hard
on the presumptions to make them into
absolutes and doesn't have any coherent
way of trying to figure out what the
counter examples are and how they ought
to be resigned so what I'm gonna do is
to just talk for a minute or two about
the way in which one ought to deal with
these kinds of presumptions let's first
start with the one about voluntary
exchange is there any kind of
circumstance in which an exchange that
is voluntary or to be distrusted well in
the usual case the answer is no because
most of the externalities to the
transaction turn out to be positive
rather than negative if it's an ordinary
contract for the sale of goods and both
the buyer and seller benefit from
each of them has a larger resource base
which in turn grows greater
opportunities to trade the third persons
the only externalities you have are
positive and even those those are not
formally acknowledged in the legal
system
it's another additional and strong
reason is why it is that you don't limit
the contract but on the other hand if it
turns out our contract is to kill a
third person now the externalities are
positive and the mere fact that there
are gains from trade spell great apparel
to the third party and so once you have
the third party immediately your
attitude towards contract has to flip
over these are no longer contracts for
exchange they're now conspiracies to
commit murder contracts for aiding and
abetting and something of the sort
in other cases slightly more removed
when you start doing with antitrust type
situations and monopolies
I think the classical theory is strong
enough to suggest that the gains to the
insider from comparison are smaller than
the loss inflicted upon third party so
we don't call those contracts anymore
now we start to call them cartels and
collusive arrangements of one sort or
another because of the intuitive
appreciation of what's going on the
great office of antitrust law or the
great office of regulated industry is
can we have the institutional whale with
all to distinguish between those
positive some contracts and negative
some contracts all when we put it in the
hands of judges where are you Steve are
you going to systematically get it wrong
such that the contracts to enforce have
negative consequences on third parties
and the ones that if you strike down
have positive consequences and the great
antitrust revolution in the last 40
years has been trying to get the sign
right on those things and I think for
the most part has done a tolerably good
job what about the other situation when
you start looking about the presumption
against the use of force against other
individuals one of the things that
libertarian theories have always had a
very strong difficulty with has been
with cases of necessity and the classic
illustration is can I break into your
cabin without your consent in order to
suspect myself from being killed in a
storm can I do so even when you try to
resist my entry on the ground that it's
your property and you have a
quote-unquote absolute right to exclude
it turned out again much to my happy
amazement when you actually looked at
the common lawyer's they were more
sophisticated on this question than the
academics who are writing about them
Blackstone said
poof and off said it gross you said it
they all said which is that essentially
there is a suspension of ordinary
property rights under conditions of
necessity and that meant an effect that
the outsider could become the insider
and when the event resolved we'd have to
pay compensation for the loss of you so
for the dislocations that were treated
it became in effect a taking with just
compensation this is not only important
with respect to those odd cases of
necessity where many people will relax
and let the guy come in anyhow no matter
what the law says that certainly been
the practice in maritime cases but this
becomes the paradigm in a situation
where you're dealing with the eminent
domain problem where property may be
taken for public use upon the payment of
just compensation the difference here is
that the necessity is no longer one of
immediate survival rather it's the
question of coordination of social
resources in such a fashion that you
could put together a highway when
otherwise the holdout problem would be
very severe this in fact seems like the
small 'man Dacian of the basic
libertarian theory but in fact it's an
enormous kind of modification and it's
one I might add that has good
constitutional sanction because the
moment you start to put the form in this
particular fashion then what you have to
do is to figure out exactly how it is
that you are going to ensure that the
compensation required is going to be
paid which particular forms adventures
ought to be taken and which ones ought
not what counts as a trespass upon
another individual and what does not and
the entire sprawling takings law which
for the most part is largely chaotic in
the United States has the answer to the
question of can you meet the
justifications that we need namely can
you find yourself a situation in which
coercion when imposed upon an individual
works for his to his particular
advantage in the individual case so as
to avoid the argument that coercion and
aggression are side by side to put it in
slightly more technical terms the
standard libertarians to figures out
what you're trying to minimize in the
Social Welfare function is the use of
force and fraud but somebody who
understands that the takings issue is an
important one now is trying to minimize
two sorts of defects that cut in
opposite direction one of them is the
coercion risk and the other is the hold
at risk
and it turns out that the moment you try
to control one you increase the other so
the maximization game is rather more
difficult than it would otherwise be and
figuring out what the optimal systems of
taxation and the opposite of systems of
regulation are requires you to solve
that incredibly nightmarish problem can
you do it I think the answer is that you
can I wrote a takings book in a
bargaining with the state book in order
to do it I'm not going to try to go into
the details hair I'm just trying to
point out what the agenda starts to look
like now the second problem that one has
to face is if you got all of these
normative theories do you have a
government that can enforce them and one
of the things that one has to recognize
is that the rights that we're talking
about are hypothetically improvements
over a state of nature which none of
them are observed but one has to be able
to develop a comprehensive system of
public institutions that can finance the
protection of the rights that have been
created and here the optimal theory of
taxation is not zero taxation nor is it
a theory which says that you could do
whatever you want the question here is
not how taxes preserve Liberty which
they do to some extent but what's the
off the mobile theory of Taxation so
that we know how many taxes you could
have what their incidents and their
distribution ought to be it is
interesting on this particular question
that all careful libertarian type
thinkers have come to the same
conclusion which is they are strongly in
favor of proportion of taxes they are
deeply suspicious of head taxes they are
deeply suspicious of progressive taxes
and I think the reason for this can be
summarized in one or two sentences and
I'll leave the elaboration for another
day what is advantage about the
proportion of taxation system is that it
houses no dollar amount on the amount of
money that the state can raise to
discharge public functions so that it's
not as though in time of war you're
going to have to have low taxation when
the survival of a nation is at stake but
what it does do is it places a
limitation on the distribution of the
tax so as to be able to avoid or to
limit the political rents thinking that
takes place when everybody tries to get
a very large share of a public benefit
but to push off the cost that is borne
by somebody else in some circumstances
it turns out that general taxes are not
appropriate because of a skewed nature
of the benefits and one of the
that the nineteenth-century lawyers
understood in the 20th century lawyers
have forgotten is that the principle of
matching costs and benefits a lie at the
heart of any social system of special
assessments and that to the extent that
you will allow special assessments
without a matching principle it is
simply a massive road to factional entry
so my favorite case decided to me by
Vito Calabria was there was a question
of how it is that you decided the tax
for a road on the basis of front footage
of the nearby properties but it turned
out for 30 miles the road was boarded by
a rail ruler which is in direct
competition with it and the question was
whether or not the bat railroad
benefited from the road that it had to
pay for half its cost and the United
States Supreme said of course said of
course it did because the legislature
said something it was a complete
breakdown of the way in which the system
worked
now the question we want to ask and I
will end with this kind of discussion
for about five or six minutes is how
does this translate itself back into
constitutional law that is to the extent
that you really have a system of
political design which indicates the
things that you ought to be able to do
in the things that you want not to be
able to do tries to give you fairly
bright-line rules as to which are
acceptable in which a night recognizes
that there's some marginal cases how
does it translate out well essentially
this is a tale of two sorts of documents
one of them and I will lump them
together for these purposes is the
question of looking at constitutional
guarantees either under a strict
scrutiny or an intermediate scrutiny
standard which are fairly close together
in many cases in a practical sense and
then on the other side starting to look
at things at a rational basis test and
the basic proposition that I'm going to
take to link the political theory to the
constitutional law is if you start down
the first road and take seriously the
constitutional guarantees in almost
every case you're going to come up with
if not the right answer at least a
reasonably good approximation thereof
but on the other hand if you decide to
start down the second road and assume
that rational basis is okay you mean
exactly the opposite what you're really
saying is that if you believe that two
plus two or five and you're willing to
swear to that before a legislature then
in effect everybody with a computer is
forced to agree with you for the
purposes of the legality of the statute
in question that is to some extent the
position that bob bork has taken and why
it is that a
that the American Enterprise Institute
has to be a very broad umbrella to take
into account the different brands of
conservativism or libertarianism that
why underneath the tent I happen to be a
consistent believer in the first view
and not and a deeply suspicious of the
second and if you look at first
amendment law I think the wonderful
opinion which illustrates how to get the
skepticism right is in fact our friend
Oliver Wendell Holmes writing in dissent
in the Abrams case when he starts to
talk about it when men have come to
realize that time is upset many fighting
faced they will realize more than they
hold their own beliefs that the best
test of an ideas ability to of itself to
get accepted in the marketplace and what
he basically meant by this is before we
start to coerce those individuals who
turn out to be dangerous against us we
have to be damn well short that they
pose an imminent peril to our own safety
by which he meant quite precisely that
there has to be the immediate threat for
the use of force and essentially what
happens he developed the conjunction
with the first amendment law a
replication of the common law rules on
injunction which says that you hold back
against injunction unless there's an
imminent peril of a serious danger on
the grounds that otherwise damages after
the fact will be adequate for the
circumstances at hand and of course he
got it right because he didn't say that
this was a rule of absolute necessity or
self-evident truth he made a judgment
that this was the best test of whether
or not there's truth in an idea on the
theory that voluntary exchange in ideas
which by the way is a more complicated
market than voluntary exchanges and
goods is in fact the only way in which
we can work unless we occur to pre
commit ourselves to the belief that some
set of goods are bad and some set of
ideas are good and he just didn't
believe in that pre commitment but what
we necessarily have to say is we have
enough knowledge about the dynamics of
political debate that we are willing to
treat the proposition on freedom of
speech as a strong enough regularity
that we're going to embody it in a
constitution and once we decide to do
that it's because of exactly what I said
before is that we know enough about the
regularities of human behavior to be
deeply aware of the use of coercion on
political dissent even if we don't know
enough to know which set of ideas turn
out to be right
which ones turn out to be wrong and
essentially if you go through the first
amendment it turns to follow a fairly
close classical liberal handbook it
turns out therefore that the heads of
major intervention are the threats and
use of force the threats of use of fraud
and also the whole question of what
kinds of Taxation on various kinds of
speech related enterprises are
permissible with respect to speech and
they tend to be flat taxes and
proportionate non-discriminatory
regulation a classical liberal synthesis
in created by a group of judges in
complete ignorance of the classical
liberal synthesis that I'm talking about
that is they managed to get it right
from case-by-case adjudication without
any strong intellectual pre commitment
to the system as a whole and indeed in
many cases with deliberate antipathy to
the system as a whole now this guy
Holmes was a very elegant writer and he
wrote another case in that case was
called Lochner against New York and here
what he said is in effect if the state
wants to pass a statute which limits
certain kinds of Baker's to working only
ten hours a day it's just a question of
political will one way or another and he
says and I quote that the idea of
Liberty will be perverted if it is taken
to mean anything other than the ability
to walk around on a public street
without consent now notice this is
typical Holmes perverted is the word
that he uses to describe the Liberty to
marry the Liberty to religion in your to
pray to God in your own way the Liberty
enter into voluntary exchanges with
other individuals the Liberty to give
testimony to make a will it's a
perversion of the idea of Liberty to
talk about all those things it is ironic
that the people who understood the non
perversion of these conceptions are
people who are universally reviled today
because of their narrow understanding of
the main springs of human conduct and I
referred to those two great heroes
justice Rufus Peckham who gave the
broader definition against which Holmes
was regaling in the lock in a case and
then it turns out to be Justice
McReynolds whom I tried to use exactly
the same kind of definition to make sure
that if parents who wanted to send their
children to private schools were not
swept up by a government craze into
public institutions so let's just
understand what the origins are now if
you take the homeless position it turns
out that in effect any kind of
justification the state puts for
it is going to be okay and so on the
Lochner case will you have something
which in fact look like a very powerful
piece of class legislation which indeed
was the ground on which the statute was
attacked by the lawyers who attacked
that his attitude is I can't figure any
of this stuff out I don't have any
general vision of a way in which people
act in a legislature if the dominant
opinion wants it it is justified on the
score of Health and it's only a
Shibboleth of was a fare which goes in
the opposite direction it is worthy of
note that even though he had these
rather iconoclastic used not a single
other justice on the United States
Supreme Court at the time shared his
opinions he was and should be understood
not as the Harbhajan or a fruit of the
future but as a renegade from our
constitutional tradition now how do we
know that because he said all
Constitution makes no commitment to
either less a fair on the one hand or to
the idea that there's an organic
relation it's a very dangerous term for
all of us future fascist and organic
relation between the individual and the
state contrast that with what he said in
the Abrams case where we've staked our
all on this experiment that free trade
and ideas of what does well why not free
trade and labor unless there's some
reason why it is that we ought to oppose
it why do we want to fractionate the
inquiry when in fact we have a theory of
freedom which covers not only speech but
also contract and covers the two of them
indifferently that isn't exactly the
same fashion the great mistake of modern
constitutional law with respect to
individual rights whether it be with
occupational freedoms or with takings is
the assumption that a theory which is
good enough to explain how it is that we
work in First Amendment areas is utterly
worthless and completely contrary to
sensible facts when we are trying to
work with other areas of basically
individual activities associated with
economic behavior property rights or the
sort the great battle as far as I can
see in constitutional discourse is
whether or not we can persuade ourselves
that the principles of classical
liberalism which have very deep and
powerful roots are strong enough to
allow us to organize our Constitution
because recall our Constitution is not a
pure libertarian doctrine it does
recognize taxation it does recognize the
power to
damn it does recognize the ability to
overcome collective action problems it
meets all of the standard devices that
we have to worry about did it
intuitively and the great tragedy or I
think modern jurisprudence for which I
hold some but not all judges responsible
you're exempted Steve is in fact that
they had the heritage handed to them on
a silver platter
and they managed to throw it away thank
you I'll take a breath does anyone have
a glass of water by the skepticism in
your art the rulings and the reference
to homes and so forth there is no is our
ability to have knowledge about the
gains and losses to individuals that we
could legislate from the centum what the
terms of exchange ought to be because we
really think that the knowledge we have
which is strong enough not only to
regulate the case for exchange is strong
enough to regulate the terms of exchange
then we have no resistance against
subjective or from the centralization of
government power and so forth and indeed
in some primitive societies you can make
the argument that those that the centers
had sufficiently powerful knowledge
differentials on you know what the means
of production were that they would
offset whatever advantages people had on
their own preference sets I mean that's
a complicated argument but the role of
skepticism is essentially a role which
starts to indicate we don't know enough
about what people want to tell them what
they ought to have and that becomes the
anti paternalistic sign and the point of
the regularity of the situation is that
we know enough about the general
tendencies to see the general positive
some games that come out of the
voluntary exchange so that's what the
what the theorem is and i disremember
let me just make it one other thing i
hope in one deep sense there's
absolutely nothing new in anything that
I've said the only kind of political
theory that makes any sense is that
which draws from all parts of the
tradition and tries to put them together
in a way that's a little bit different
which is traditionally done so that you
could start to see the can
actions and draw the best out of these
various traditions and I try to do that
with utilitarian and social contract
tradition I try to do it with the
pleading tradition which I didn't even
talk about today and I sort of try to do
it with the biological tradition and the
ontological tradition you try to get it
all together and the job is everybody's
got the notes out there your view is to
figure out if you could turn them into a
nice and melody okay any other questions
yes John oh my god a lot nothing is new
what's up John you talked about
externalities in terms of force in terms
of purposes is it simply that once you
open up that can of worms that is surely
in terms of the wealth maximizing
principle that you talk to Barrow surely
some extent well absolutely
this is another long part of the
discussion which I don't have here but
right which I do try to talk about in
the book and elsewhere which is what's
the appropriate definition of an
externality which deals with the
question of regulation right I mean I
think that's the problem that you're
asking and here in a sense what happens
is they are turn out to be a large
number of externalities which in the
long run average advantage it is in
everybody's interest that we ignore and
so if you start to try to figure out the
way in which the force externalities
profile themselves it turns out that in
a civilized society thank god they're
relatively large in magnitude relatively
infrequent in severity and to the extent
that you want to stop those things it's
like getting the low-hanging fruit and
keeping the things in order the moment
you start to switch to certain other
kinds of externalities ie you managed to
practice a religion of which I am NOT a
part and a duly offends me we have to
start to recognize that this is
perfectly reciprocal unlike the use of
force it turns out that you practice in
a religion which offends me and so now
each of us has a complete place to ban
the other so what we do is we put people
functionally behind a veil of ignorance
we say if we're going to allow these
kinds of preferences about external
behavior to work for you they're gonna
have to work for me are we better off
given enforcement cost and so forth in
recognizing these externalities in both
cases or denying them in both cases and
I think when you run the mental
experiment and make the empirical
judgment because these are
empirical judgments it's going to be
pretty clear that the Toleration
principle is going to beat the others
and of course the ancient lawyers beat
us to this the expression that they used
to cover exactly these kinds of cases
and also cases of competitive industry
injuries same kind of thing was damnum
absque where in europe it meant that
there was a home you don't want to
pretend that there's a theory of
causation which sort of makes these
things disappear there's no necessary
truth here as with any other libertarian
proposition but without injury in the
sense that we now make a social judgment
that these things are not going to be
actionable and economists ought to call
these things sometimes pecuniary
externalities or various other terms
which again is designed to capture the
notion that the simple fact that
somebody is left worse off by somebody
else's action is not an of itself enough
reason to justify the imposition of
legal force and sure enough if you start
to look to the First Amendment where
again they actually care about getting
it right for whatever reason that
doctrine is announced over and over
again so if it's a question about the
flag salute cases for example the mere
fact that large numbers of Americans are
offended that the Jehovah's Witness
won't sign up to the Pledge of
Allegiance is no reason to coerce them
into that kind of belief notwithstanding
the real harms the other way or the fact
that many Americans are offended that
certain people wish to burn their own
flags is not enough under the First
Amendment to allow it so what we do is
in a consistent area when you really
care about Liberty you really care about
the definition of harm when you don't
give a damn about the liberties as in
the economic cases anything counts as
harm including competitive industries so
that every piece of reactionary statute
one anti-dumping laws for example all
use the definition of home offense to
others competitive industry which are
exactly rejected in the First Amendment
area so when you're talking about the
differences in the theories it runs
really deep all the way down to the
absolute bottom there is not a single
issue which does not have an analogous
problem in the two areas which get
completely different solution and one
gives you a legislative supremacy and
the most god-awful system of intrigue
and the other gives you in fact a system
of limited government which turns out to
be stable over twenty years now why is
that important because it goes to our
friend Williams over there
so many people said the problem about my
system is no judge could ever do it
they're too stupid too vain to ignorant
I mean the judges even say that about
themselves my view about is how could
they make that argument when they've
already done it in at least one area
which is every bit as fraught with
political difficulty and even though you
can find things that are wrong like with
New York Times and Sullivan at the edges
and so forth they basically got at 80 to
90 percent right when you look to the
federalism area it's the same framework
that applies was competitive federalism
within the state eighty to ninety
percent right when they don't cry eighty
to ninety percent wrong it seems to me
it's worth the effort
don't sell yourself short I'm gonna take
another question for somebody else yes
yeah you here oh no property rights in
this room okay woman she does precisely
as she wants and does exactly as she
pleases
living her life free from strife today
but they said a little woman in your
life all right so this is essentially
the less a fair version of Liberty that
was driving him to distraction and
healthy married
since yo we got a Supreme Court and if
they dominated by the president with the
advice instead of these I basically have
committed suicide to new existence
the result doesn't the political
atmosphere have to change so drastically
and in fact such a bunch even applying
rational-basis would come out right I
think Ohno it does matter no no if you
win it politically you will win it for a
short time you'll have a Gingrich
revolution that will work for six months
and then it will start to decay again
the theory about this I mean I oh that's
a different question I mean the question
of how we get this implemented given the
current state of affairs the answer is
quite simply not that you win
regrettably you lose when we get you on
the court which is a start I mean at
least on the things you know and frankly
you are much more faithful to these
principles than you would otherwise
acknowledge but that's okay you don't
have to confess I don't want to have an
impeachment hearing brought in the short
run but no I think the the serious point
about this is the reason we engage in
political debate is not because in a
large society we get transformations of
a sudden nature based upon a nice theory
by a single person but what happens is
it influences the climate of a companion
and if you have a large and complex
society and you can move things one or
two degrees all of a sudden if I'm right
then when people start looking at
Chevron deference they differ a little
bit less to an administrative agency and
then you start striking down some
various things and in the takings law
all of a sudden defenses that used to
work fail so you get Palazzolo for
example which comes out the right way to
the horror of large numbers of people
and it also means that when you get in
the political debates you can now
articulate a set of principles that
aren't so utterly crazy that people on
the other side could win by ridicule I
mean the number of times they know oh
you're all libertarian this was told to
me today by John echeverría you're a
libertarian so you don't believe that
the polluter ought to play with respect
to tort damages right I said why do you
think that he says because pollution
isn't a nuisance I said where did you
get that because it comes from any
source what about a class action I mean
it gets absolutely crazy and slowly but
surely the point of having intellectual
discourse is that ideas have
consequences I'm not trying to get
anyone's time revolution I'm not running
a coup but on well so long as I'm
willing to take the abuse from people
who aren't my friends maybe I'm going to
hear a little bit of compliments from
those who ought to be that's
the only thing that I'm said all right
Roger oh my god oh my rides gonna throw
me a cream puff come on back to your
principle of necessity Richard oh you
don't like that run no I in fact your
earlier allusion was to my earlier
writings which like yours were more
ambitious than the evidence warned in
any event the principle of necessity as
you know that's ordinarily or ideally
accompanied by a rule of subsequent
compensation and it is not used
invariably does not use for example the
body parts that's correct and the
bifurcation is what concerns me there
because of course there is the analogue
on the social level with caroling
products flick note for the bifurcation
of the Bill of Rights and so forth how
do you keep if you're going to use these
elementary principles of individual
exchange from serving as models for
subsequent social decision making
whereby we distinguish oh it's okay to
take property because if that's only
property and then you have your usual
first amendment economic liberties
things that you start to do is you go
back again to the common law rules and
sometimes they're very instructive under
circumstances of necessity the common
law rules which I think of the right
norms never required you to expend your
labor in order to assist another what we
did is relied on a principle of
volunteerism to do that and one of the
reasons we did is that we didn't want to
get people into the possible situation
that once they started they get
themselves into big trouble and we know
for the most part in the 19th century
the level of volunteerism if anything
may have been excessive relative to the
risks in question that as people would
do so much to try to help folks that
that was never an issue and I think that
that's really the a very accurate
description of the level of cooperation
that took place when you're talking
about prop necessity the rule would only
apply with respect to the use of
somebody else's property and if the doc
was there
your basic judgment was that the
implicit influence that it might have
had on prior decisions of whether or not
to build would be so negligible that
there'd be no distortion with respect to
the conduct
question and no danger of actually
exposing some other risks person to
bodily injury of his own so that what
happens is the only duty that you as the
doc gonna have when the other fellow was
coming up is to step aside it is not
necessarily to give assistance this is
not a perfect rule but in a
rough-and-ready world it certainly
captures the anxieties now let's go back
to the body parts case this is the
famous illustration of Judith's Javas
Thompson and a thing that she wrote on
necessity in the 1985 Yale reviewing
Yale Law Journal maybe somewhere else
and she says look you got yourself a
situation where you're driving a truck
or our trolleys what she said and you're
on a track and is deciding to the right
and you discovered that the brakes in
fact fail and now you can either turn to
the right and kill one person to go
straight ahead and kill five what do you
do
everybody goes turns and kills only one
and saves fine and assume they're all
workman now she says a patient comes
into your office and it turns out that
he's a healthy patient and you've got
five people and it just so happens this
is the just-so world that if you
dismember this person you can give one
login to each of these five people and
save five lives do you do it and well
the first thing you know is it doesn't
pass the giggle test because I saw Steve
laugh and the answer is you dumb
well the question is wine and to a great
philosopher she couldn't see the
difference because there was both the
trade of one and fun but the answer is
crystal clear it's is that what are you
trying to do with respect to antecedent
condom if in fact you impose the
liability on him for hitting the one or
the five you will minimize it and then
effect will take antecedent precautions
to avoid both so that the long-term
incentives that you create by the
imposition of liability will get you as
close to the optimum as you possibly
have the long-term effect of the other
rule if we announced it as the end of
the medical profession because no
healthy person is ever going to go in
and at this time we can start to see
empirical differences between the two
kinds of rules now Judith Jarvis
Thompson is a very brilliant philosopher
but it's exactly the ignorance of the
way in which legal rules tie into
behaviors over two periods they stand an
economic question the trade-off that you
have between the gains you get in the
first period and the losses in the
second the inability to see that as a
serious kind of social issue these you
to state
things that are laughable and the reason
they're laughable is because the deep
structure of our trade offs which is our
major things since this is just very
very bad so what do you do you try to
organize structurally a voluntary market
for all these exchange is it going to
work it will do maybe a little bit of
good with respect to kidneys but only if
it's above ground because it turns out
if you actually and this is something I
do know something about if you're trying
to organize an organ market one-to-one
exchanges are absolutely useless because
of all the matching difficulties you
have to have a network the only way you
can get in network is to have an
intermediate and a broken to pull the
organs at the pool the people and that
can only be done if you have legal
enforcement to the full set of
arrangements when you get a lot of bars
yeah you get a lot of bars we get a lot
of cells no um because it turns out that
there's a risk to sacrificing a kidney
even if it's done perfectly and I don't
want to go into all the gory details of
what can go wrong when it's not done
perfectly so in the short one we should
allow this it will do a little bit of
good in the long run what do we do we
better get ourselves a better system of
animal technology so we can use pigs
organs to replace the kidneys and if we
do that at that point we will solve the
problem and the point about necessity is
we don't want to talk about global
necessities for organs as being the same
thing as an immediate instantaneous
accessory which means that this guy has
to go on this dock and so it's the
equivocation in the term which is
certainly sensible enough in terms of
getting a program which means that we
have very different responses one we
have the timeframe for institutional
response and in the other case we don't
know I know there's a question over here
yes and we need a microphone currently
the greatest threats to the first
amendment would it be religious
expression in political campaigns or
religious expression outside abortion
clinics or could it be campaign finance
all I mean you know the First
Amendment's a pretty big subject like
the takings cause I think the biggest
threat to First Amendment is none of the
particulars notions but rather exactly
the opposite there are many fashionable
academics who start to believe that you
really can't believe in freedom of
speech because the inequality of
resources are such that you have to have
an extensive system of government
regulation to make sure that there's
parity in the marketplace in other words
what they do is they say oh yes we do
believe in the marketplace of ideas and
we think it ought to be subject to the
same regulations that are now
permissible in the marketplace for good
and with that starts to come in there
everything's gonna fall into place at
once with the change in attitude yes you
will have all sorts of campaign
financing based upon arguments of
fundamental asymmetries and market power
driven by differential abilities and
wealth and you are going to have
limitations on the ability of people to
speak in political areas because of the
incompetence of the audience that listen
to them and you are gonna have vast
restrictions on commercial speech
because everybody knows that to tell the
truth really is to tell a lie because
the audience is so stupid that it can't
understand and all we need to make this
thing really go south is the idea that
we take over the rational basis test
based upon this view of human nature
into the area of speech is it happening
well I think for the most part probably
not and I think that the justices have
kept the line reasonably good but it's
sort of something which is very
worrisome because inside the Academy
today it is very clear that the civil
libertarians view of speech is actually
in a minority relative to the
regulator's my favorite illustration of
this is my colleague very esteemed
colleague Cass Sunstein wrote a book
which is called free speech and the
rather free speech and the problem with
democracy is that what he's our or
democracy in the problem of free speech
if the title belongs the other way it
should be free speech in the problem of
democracy that is the real danger is
that of politics overwhelming freedom
it's not the danger of freedom
overwhelming politics I mean it is it's
that kind of trade-off that one really
has to worry about
look the basic proposition is this in
its own unconscious ways general
philosophical propositions permeate
particular decisions and justice that
happened with the harm issue that we
were taught
they abound in speech it happens all the
way through it's not that anybody is
smart enough a dumb enough perhaps to
figure it all out that's our academic
job but lawyers even if they don't have
it in the abstract they instinctively
know which position they take in the
concrete case and so their ability to
call the comprehensive system by pieces
is far greater I think then it's
sometimes appreciated when do you want
me to call it a day my friend like now
okay Richard Epstein is a law professor
at the University of Chicago and author
of principles for a free society
property and freedom and mortal peril
his forthcoming book is called
skepticism and freedom a defence of
classical liberalism and it will be
published by the University of Chicago
Press you can visit press dot you
Chicago dot edu to get more information